welcome to this video against
Grandmaster lingo from Norway I want so
many GM noise with gm's from Norway's
you don't have okay let's play d6 again
unlife Johanna's nuts lingo I thought he
had some some other handle ok I was
successful let's get rid of this window
and was successful with the philly door
before ah this G for light yeah this is
sheer offs g4 line it is it is tricky I
think black needs to take it but i am
only looked at this a real long time ago
I looked at this is even though I saw
that this is this a line and black plays
something like this age 62 cover g5 and
he goes he needs to really a tread
carefully
yeah black young is very very rare for
behind development but it's it's own
it's not a closed position but it's not
exactly open open either like an yeah
it's hard to develop you cannot play the
bishop because the port is hanging on g7
and where do you get your king and when
you cannot castle short and out of the
question probably you will never manage
yeah and this kind of moves are I in in
this g6 is going to play a form probably
hmm can I go night-night b6 intending
Knight g4 is this in any way you move
probably not here and each other I need
to move this is really a quite quite
terrible line to face if you don't don't
know it I guess that's probably a way to
to get an OK position but it's a it's
very very tough to to play this can I go
night for now I will I'd love to get
this this Bishop to be a bit more secure
on the dark squares of course I'm not
developing I know but still getting this
piece would be it would be excellent if
he if he does an exchange sack ok he
didn't was probably a [ __ ] anyway ok
so but now 9 let's let's take special
first and now see what's going on that
that I got the bishop is really huge
because the dark squares are the
sensitive squares and my setup so g6 or
you can also just just grab this thing
here takes a 5 pawn takes and long
castle it's probably not not not
terrible but is it the best probably not
i can take here oh it why not i can take
just here
and now in Thai take on f5 or what if
what if i play g6 x naught g6 actually
if you return special g7 I mean it's
it's it's a strong bishop not quite sure
why I should give up the two bishops
here
k bisha p.m.
now I can try to to play for castles
long castles I mean but even short isn't
out of the question now I mean without
the dark squared bishop and i have it on
g7 mind i can't think of castling short
it's not done it's not out of the
question
this should be a draw of course not it
would be a bit silly okay but yeah it
would be with Sonny but damn what else
case takes g5 and Shaq doesn't really
help him much I've got Queenie seven
so f6 is this a threatening move
hmm yeah probably it is and this means
yeah it's got he's got f65 in the
position
okay I don't have a choice that this was
this is where it was very good for black
disposition and now it's probably the
other way around not not so clear
1975 yeah my bishop on eight it was a
great piece on g7 maybe this is still ok
but it wasn't what I would I hoped for
of course ok
yeah this is the problem it's it's all
very very shaky now and of course that
the time situation doesn't help
not sure why to where I should have
played played differently gal 95 also
pretty strong rules
I didn't really calculate the carbon
capture I need to do to be a quick up
yeah I'm are still alive maybe Joe I'm
not I'm not alive I'm great here time
warning aah jet jet
check
check
yeah I'm not quite sure how I want this
but I did somehow yeah I don't know very
very difficult just so difficult to
assess this I was our surely in bad
shape Ian there's no no question I
thought around here black was excellent
but maybe maybe I'm overestimating
things yeah my deaf five I can't play
Bishop f8 and probably I should do that
yeah he's still still active here and
this is this is now dead difficult he
had the computers is just a fearless he
wants to play Bishop f6 but I simply
Bishop I have six rookie one I don't
know I don't I didn't know he computers
saying this is great for black yeah
maybe it is it's possible it's possible
if I get to play d5 how does he attack
me yeah it's probably a safe safe
position computers very often it is
right I didn't I this looked also this
looked bad to me but the computer just
says here and and black is much better
yeah then this was the solution but I
didn't want to play that it was clear
that this is this is as I actually I
expected bishop age three check and then
d 5 but he went for this immediately
okay
oops sorry wrong button
yeah and now this is this shocking move
yeah and it's running up ok computer
gives this as a win but ok i simply i
didn't want to retake squint eggs it
looks terrible so i went here yeah and
this the computer actually gives queen
f1 yeah but ok no human with one minute
on the clock is going to find that Queen
f1 hmm
not quite sure that I even understand
the move I understand some of it I mean
you need to move the Queen but yeah
after this I'm probably still alive it's
a no no this is winning now but ok it's
it's 30 seconds against 20 and in the
end I think he was so irritated that he
didn't they didn't win the the game on
93 I missed but ok 13 seconds I
basically needed to do pre moves and
then at the end I I was winning I've got
two extra points now yeah thanks for
watching good fight